He started it I ended it but you know what he was
doing as I caved in his skull he was laughing
he laughed at me because he won it's over for me
now it's over the city is yours now let's save it
be a better batman Welcome back everyone this
is going to be my titans season 3 episode 1 to
3 video they dropped the first three episodes
on hbo max obviously they're doing a version
of under the red hood so i'll explain what's
going on with that what they're doing between
batman the joker nightwing and the other titans
characters because there's a couple different big
story lines that they're weaving in here if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos and obviously spoiler warning for the
first three episodes if you haven't seen those yet
although most of what we're going to be talking
about is from the first two episodes although
there are a lot of wtf moments in all the episodes
primarily it's the first two episodes where they
cover a lot of the batman versus joker and the
red hood storyline it'll continue through the
rest of the season but i believe that starfire's
sister blackfire is meant to be the main villain
of season three so red hood isn't going to be
the main villain even though it seems like he
is in these first couple of episodes but the whole
idea is that they opened the season literally with
jason todd just monitoring the police scanner
and catching track of the joker who seems
like he's been an amusement mile like he kills a
couple cops and leaves a trail to amusement mile
but the way they're playing this is if the joker
is actually playing four-dimensional chess with
batman and he actually left a trap for jason
like the whole situation was meant to be a trap
to kill jason or seemingly kill him in order to
entrap batman and force him to kill the joker and
that was going to be the joker's way of beating
him his ultimate victory so even though they're
not really clear about that it just seems like
that was the game the joker was playing the whole
time like yeah it seems like jason was just going
rogue like he drops an f-bomb and then says he's
going to get the joker after bruce specifically
tells him no way like it's not about being afraid
it's not about proving anything to me it's just
too dangerous so batman is basically flying home
when this is happening so he's unable to go rush
help jason there's a lot of discussion from all
the characters taking batman to task about what
he's like as a father like are you good are you
actually putting all these children in danger and
then obviously one of the other huge moments from
the episode is later when nightwing finds out that
he's actually looking through a bunch of files
of other candidates for the next robin that's
actually going to be tim drake because they are
doing the comic book easter eggs and after jason
todd wound up dying batman's next robin wound
up being tim drake in the comics we only saw him
briefly at the beginning of the episode reacting
to jason todd's death so we'll probably won't
check in with him again until a little bit later
in the season i'm a fan batman's a sociopath in a
rubber snm outfit pick better heroes kid i believe
they've already renewed the show for season four
so i'm actually kind of expecting that they turn
him into a bigger character during season four but
while nightwing is investigating this mysterious
chemical that jason had been manufacturing and
using on himself he also finds batman's files on
a bunch of other robins from the comics so there's
carrie kelly who is the robin from the dark knight
returns comics there's daxton chill stephanie
brown and duke thomas so i think that some of
these are just easter eggs and that's it but maybe
we'll see one or two of these characters show
up in the future of the series like i said tim
drake is going to be the next big robin character
eventually but not right away but the way they
pay off this batman vs joker storyline in the
titans universe because this isn't happening in
the arrowverse it's sort of like an alternate
universe the way they explain it during crisis on
infinite earth is that he goes a little bit nuts
after jason's death and even asks nightwing to
become robin again like i can't do this by myself
you got to help me and after nightwing gives him a
hard pass he just shows up later in the episode in
his room dropping this bloody crowbar saying
i did it i finally did it i killed the joker
he started it i ended it he explains he killed
joker while he was in arkham prison caved his
skull in with that crowbar he admits the joker
basically beat him that was his ultimate victory
that's why he was laughing while i was keeping
his skull in because that was the whole idea in
the first place try to kill one of his robins in
order to get batman to kill him big easter egg for
the justice league snyder cut the whole reason why
zack snyder brought jared leto's joker back for
that nightmare scene was to pay off the idea of
the dead robin from batman v superman the costume
that we saw but never really got a lot of answers
about that's why during the nightmare scene they
have a back and forth about sending a boy to do a
man's job that's his reference to a death in the
family inside the snyder verse and they have their
truce with the playing card but if you remember
earlier in the movie when you were getting
the flash forward the vision from the mother
box that cyborg got you see the ruins of the hall
of justice you see a bunch of dead justice league
members including kilwa green lantern but you
also see the joker's playing card blowing in the
wind and it's been ripped in half and that was the
whole thing the joker's truce was the minute that
you want to end our truce you rip this card in
half and then we'll kill each other all you have
to do is tear in half and i'm happy to discuss
with you anyway like why you sent a boy wonder
to do a man's job and make no mistake
i will kill you then i do it slow
i'm gonna honor that promise so we're just paying
that idea off that in this timeline this potential
future the cyborg was seeing batman did wind up
killing the joker when it comes to batman's no
kill rule it just depends on which director
which producer which writer is working on
the character because we're going to be seeing
michael keaton's batman in the flash movie and
potentially other future crossover movies if you
go back and you watch the tim burton batman movies
his batman winds up killing a ton of people
the body count is super high in those movies
so batman killing the joker is a huge deal and i
think the reason why they did the biggest reason
at least is because they weren't going to be
able to do a really huge version of the joker
the way that they wanted to or the way that you as
a fan would want them to we've already got so many
different versions of the joker in the dc movies
right now jared leto's joker is still alive until
proven otherwise don't know when we're going to
see him again after the justice league snyder cut
we have the joaquin phoenix joker from the joker
movie they're legit talking about doing a sequel
to that now and then matt reeves has his new
robert pattinson batman movie trilogy and they'll
eventually probably introduce another separate new
version of the joker during that and also because
they have so many versions of batman that we're
going to see the next couple years like michael
keaton batman in the flash movie ben affleck's
batman is coming back during that as well i've
already done a video about the preview video for
ben affleck's batman in that movie that we got
so i'll put a link for that in the description
and obviously robert pattinson's batman movie
happening next year so i think the titans people
were like okay we're probably not going to be able
to do a ton of batman in a batman costume the way
that fans would want us to so we need a reason for
him to not be around every week so him killing
the joker going a little bit crazy and then
just taking off her parts unknown to make another
dead robin joke kills two birds with one stone the
other big reveals from this episode or they reveal
why it is that barbara gordon the oracle version
of barbara gordon has become the new police
commissioner because her father jim gordon they
play it like it's been a while but he was killed
by mister freeze and the reason why she kind of
hates batman during the episode or at least thinks
very poorly of him is because she believes that
working with him in fighting crime the way that
they did or at least using their methods is what
got him killed whereas batman tries to rationalize
it saying that jim gordon knew what the price was
he knew that he would eventually probably die
in the line of duty gotham was just that kind of
place all the batman rogues gallery of villains
would eventually wind up killing some of them
also just a little bit of context in history
because she's in the wheelchair that means that
they've already had their version of the killing
joke story line and it seems like it's been a
while since that happened it's been a while since
she's been batgirl there's a lot of weird tension
between her and nightwing so i think it's kind of
implied that at one point they had a relationship
like they did in the comics but as of right now
in present day they're not super close with each
other although they do acknowledge the history
that they have with each other the return of red
hood all the red hood stuff doesn't really start
till episode two and they actually opened the
episode with a little bit of a time jump in him
showing up killing a bunch of mob members claiming
that he's in charge now he took care of batman
in that the mob is going to have to pay him for
protection if you ever watched the animated under
the red hood movie with jensen ackles it's a great
movie from a long time ago but it's basically
that story line with him going around killing mob
members just killing people in the way that batman
refused to kill a lot of people they haven't fully
explained how he came back to life because during
episode one batman just tells nightwing after the
fact oh we buried him next to alfred's plot in the
cemetery but you never see the body you only hear
later that he came back and someone was tampering
with it when they're all trying to figure out how
it is they came back to life they do mention ray
shaw ghoul and the lazarus pit because that is
how they did it during the comics but the way they
explained it ray shaw ghoul hasn't been anywhere
near gotham in a long time so they kind of crossed
him off the list like well it probably wasn't the
lazarus pit probably some other method i think
the reason they did it this way is because they
don't plan on doing the racial ghoul character on
titans anytime soon there's a bunch of other stuff
that they try to set up for later in the season
like there's all the starfire blackfyre stuff
off in the background but i think for right
now it's mostly about them versus red hood
i don't even talk too much about scarecrow they
actually have vincent kartheiser playing a version
of scarecrow on the tv show he's kind of like
their version of hannibal lecter but when he
shows up in the episodes for the first time he's
been in arkham asylum for a long time having been
put there by batman and even though raven seems
like she's a real big character this season there
isn't a ton of her in the first couple of episodes
they do find out that she's actually busy trying
to revive donna troy on themyscira if you saw the
trailer videos that i did earlier this year you
do see that donna troy does come back during the
season so that's obviously a big comic book thing
too her dying and then seemingly coming back to
life but that really just scratches the surface
so there's any big questions you have about what's
going on or the big wtf moments or what's going
on with their version the joker red hood or
batman or they're under the red hood storyline
just write it below in the comments there's a ton
of easter eggs that i don't really get into during
this video but i just wanted to cover the really
big wtf moments i just did a huge breakdown video
for the suicide squad movie so i'll put a link for
that down in the description you can click here
for my full suicide squad post credit scene video
and click here for my full marvel what if episode1
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!